tears and anger those are just some of
the reactions and calls and emails to
our newsroom regarding the problems at
heights funeral home in henderson thanks
for joining us here at five i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis the business
had its license suspended after a number
of alleged violations were discovered
including bodies being stacked on top of
each other and viewers were upset that
someone they lost was still there joe
muller is live near the business at
boulder highway and sunset with their
concerns tonight joe
well since the suspension a number of
you have contacted our newsroom i'm
concerned about loved ones now we're
outside of heights funeral home here in
henderson
this location was on probation for a
number of complaints since the winter
that was until yesterday when the
state's funeral board suspended the
license for six months after the
executive director says she stopped by
and noticed bodies being stacked and
bodies wrongly being handled among other
issues many of you emailed called and
commented on social media about the
service they had and others worried
about loved ones at the facility
including carol gonzalez who had her
daughter's remains moved from the
site today
she's been there since the 15th
and i wasn't getting much answers from
the heights mortuary
and she's unfortunately she was there in
that mess that i saw in the story
you know unbelievable with the flies
there on the bodies and the bodies
stacked up some not refrigerated
and it's um that's not the way to treat
loved ones or in family members
after the vote to suspend the license
heights was told it has 30 days to have
the bodies they have in their care
cremated or buried if someone wanted to
have their loved one moved before that
they need to make arrangements with a
funeral home some raise concerns about
whether or not they get the correct
remains well back out here live
according to the cremation institute in
order to make sure it is correct keep
record of the document tag that
accompanies the body through the process
reporting live in henderson joe muller